What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we'll be trying to play table tennis on different heights!
Can't really hit so hard here!
Ok, this is my secret strategy.
No!
Ace!
Wait, that's illegal.
I made Otto move!
It was my turn!
No.
Now this is suitable for you
I'm gonna like this
You got it.
Roller!
I think this is the right tactic for this
This is actually quite enjoyable!
You know what Otto
I think this is the most comfortable way to play the game
The lazy man's table tennis
I know what to use for this
Ok Emil!
Choose your weapon.
I choose this one.
Oh, you take the badminton.
Your turn
Now it's your turn
Imagine if you were like 4 meters high
And playing table tennis would feel like this
It would require a really good footwork!
Alright make sure to subscribe to our channel here!
And watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!
Otto are you impressed with my skills?
Yes.
Good.